we celebrate all the women who directed
phenomenal films from strong social
messages to heartfelt speeches
moments that left us puzzled and even a
surprise performance that shocked the
audience PT is taking a look at the most
memorable moments from the 2020 Academy
Awards did such a great job in Harriet
hiding black people that the Academy got
her to hide all the black nominees the
stars wasted no time poking fun at the
Oscars for the lack of women and
diversity in the nominees Laura Dern won
for Best Supporting Actress
she told the reporters backstage she
wished her award could have gone to
someone else if I could give this Oscar
to Greta Gerwig I would do it right now
Natalie Portman made a statement with
her outfit wearing a Dior embroidered
cape that had the names of female
directors who were snubbed there was
also some political commentary like this
moment during Brad Pitt's Best
Supporting Actor speech
it told me only have 45 seconds up here
which is 45 seconds more than the Senate
gave John Bolton this week what does
this night mean and what it could be and
the excitement of tonight um it is that
it's our you know it's our highest honor
and it's exciting you know it's a long
it's a long run so it's exciting to get
to the end it's exciting too for it to
be the biggest of the biggest and it'll
be exciting to you know get back to work
again frozen to star Josh GAD introduced
his co-star Idina Menzel's performance
naturally he didn't miss the chance to
remind us about John Travolta's epic
flub when he infamously mispronounced
her name the iconic and brilliant
idina menzel pronounced exactly as it is
spelled is our elsa and she's here
tonight joined by Aurora and Elsa's from
around the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's an amazing experience to be joined
in solidarity by all these women from
all over the world it's been a very
powerful few days for all of us put your
mom's idea
[Music]
[Music]
in couples news Leonardo DiCaprio made
his first official appearance with his
girlfriend Camila Marone the 22 year old
actress smiled big at her man as they
sat front and center
funny gals Maya Rudolph and Kristen Wiig
chose to sing while announcing the
nominees for best costume design and we
got an interesting reaction out of Billy
Eilish
[Music]
another moment that left people puzzled
when James Corden and rebel Wilson
walked out on stage like this nobody
more than us understands the importance
of good visual effects but the most
shocking moment of the night a surprise
performance by Eminem who sang the song
he won the Oscar for in 2003
[Music]
m's performance had the audience feeling
all types of ways idina menzel looked
confused
so did Martin Scorsese but stars like
Anthony Ramos couldn't get enough gal
gadot twas clearly loving it so was
kelly marie tran eminem is there i know
my favorite what did you take yeah it's
so great he's finally made an appearance
finally i'm waiting in waiting
never a dull moment at the oscars even
during its final moments the cast and
crew of parasite took the stage to
accept the last award of the night for
Best Picture but during the middle of
their speech the lights dimmed which
didn't sit well with the crowd
[Applause]
and today
[Music]